Jim you're alive what's that you're
alive yeah I had to go upstairs to pee
because they do the bathrooms at this
time it's so stupid really
it's what time is it it's nine thousand
five oh and they clean I know it does
really this first world problems but
there's too many bathrooms why won't
this cleaning crew clean our bathrooms
on time well they should because we're
on the air and we go right now and they
and instead of doing these earlier they
do it the middle of these morning shows
that what the [ __ ] you're doing
right yeah I mean not say need to
realize who the most important people
here are yes the white ones well Jim's
got a big a big special it's awesome to
me that he's filming and you know Jim
likes to stay relevant yeah stylish
young stay stylish Davis and I mean
Joanne you and I both know mmm can I go
live with this unveiling you can go
ahead yeah I got it okay so Frank knows
- he's gone Facebook live I'll go alive
he gets it I refuse you don't your
facebook live at all why it's good
Facebook live is great it'll be
something yeah hang on wait a minute you
don't need you know what you know you're
kind of done letting people in a little
bit I thought well I always it start
some people are just create I don't your
life and I can't win hey yeah hey how's
it going you want to be accessible but
not too excessive yeah now especially
for a woman there's a thin line yeah
yeah you'd only two accessible with
creepy people yeah understandable yeah
and at some point like they've
especially doing your doing before when
you were on TV as much as you were hmm
it's like no no no I know you I know
your opinions I know how you feel yeah I
feel the same way we share that yeah
especially like the Joanne you really
shouldn't drink as much the concerned
fans no white knight coming in to sit
that's like a sort of character that was
put on for me like I either way you
don't drink that I was hoping that was
true I do not healthy thirst but I'm a
small person and I know my limits go
yeah but either way you have to just
live it like her like because you have
people on social media that just want to
take care of like Hollywood is not gonna
want to hire a boozing actress Joanne
going down yeah that's never that's
never happened in Hollywood somebody's
alcohol problem no nothing does not fly
does not I you must be looking so much
forward to like the episode of Gotham
airing so it's like there's your first
thing and you can finally have people be
like and I'm almost positive they didn't
cut me out because uh post-production
had emailed me to check on the spelling
of my name for billing oh that's great
so you know that's I'm gonna be on
credit yeah that's nice
yeah Beach we're gonna get cut out and
you don't find out right away huh or you
tell everyone to watch and you're not
there I heard they don't do that anymore
like at a premiere they'll tell you
you've been taken out uh have you ever
been told that you were cut out of
something I've never not been told I was
caught of something I've not been caught
out they actually just had me do my
scenes in the cutting room yeah I know I
am is it jim has won an award for DVD
extras yeah it's just in bonus scene
yeah okay my favorite I have to oh
that's what I tell myself that's the
best part right this is for the real fan
that's right yeah I got cut out at rider
funny scene trainwreck and I got cut out
and they told me what I was going to do
a tiara so bummed like [ __ ] sorry yeah
that's okay you're obviously I don't
know if it's meant to be like this
you're taking it in good news yeah I
know no no no no best thing ever
happened to me yeah yeah it's probably
better yeah yeah really good what's
meant to happen yeah yeah the pressures
that come with that yeah I need a
hundred million dollar film yeah what
needs it I don't have to deal with any
of those pesky royalty checks when you
get cut out right not true oh you see
it's still gonna get the money
Oh
it's like we know who's paying for lunch
today these are guns alike yeah gonzo
Wow oh yeah no they are they pay me and
I I don't even know how listed an IMDB
but I am getting paid time in the movies
right credits well unlike Joanne Jim is
still making his living being Jim he's
got to be Jim Norton which means he has
to put his best foot forward like what
you did there what is the matter
whenever segue his best foot the
delivery is just thank you thank you
just you know you hate it when people
don't get it so you repeat that yes well
you laugh at yourself yeah yeah I do
that way people understand um I have two
boxes of Easy's two boxes of a $2,000
shoes which I got for uh $20 yeah these
are not the actual parameter where I
left them home because I want to damage
them again he of course they're easiest
I mean they're the hottest you know you
can tell that Jim is is super hip he
spelled Yeezys with an S instead of a
see I was a mistake oh yeah busy I was
typing here I may seem like an S on the
box is that is that what it is
oh no okay not a miss so that was more
just not just an older man an older man
making an older man mistake yeah yeah
yeah mistake for younger I was in a
phrase like that yeah but as I say
distract advantage right just like I
write like probably like ah pass me by a
little bit refer to Facebook as the
Facebook that's how you're the MTV yeah
that's where you're in a different age
bracket evie the in front of everything
yeah an older person thing so let's see
the easies Jim you've never used to do
thing about the soda bottle remember
that you saw my grandmother's sake El
Cap yeah and so yeah soda bottle so just
have a joke about that I don't state
yeah what was it a joke no I honestly I
honestly don't remember I problem sure
was something with hitting with a hammer
yeah in any specific like the old movies
when the people didn't get what they
wanted they would take their Chanukah
like that oh yeah yeah yeah I got a
special I think yeah that was a keeper I
second that one for a long time yeah
ringing yeah ah when you bite the fist
yeah awesome point was that yeah he does
yeah he bites his feet by cazar yeah
that's I just hopped on
Wow there is something very funny about
being so angry I guess so man my uber
driver that bit my hand
you me you're like your palm no I bit
this plot with a thumb and forefinger my
uber went the wrong way I bit into my
hand I was so angry yeah you got express
yourself bro yeah yeah heard other
people not assigning room to great
tattoo
what uh what which one should open I
guess they're the open box what are the
the what the unopened box go for the
let's um what let's do this yeah we're
filming this and everything is this
gonna be big people like you know this
is an unboxing yeah yeah is what it is
this is great big stuff yeah yeah take a
photo
yeah Joanne you haven't gotten to get a
pair of Yeezys have you know I do get a
pair of black high top poem of sneakers
are nice they are my favorite few of
them I feel like I can do anything and
like break into like some pop and lock
routine right I love pop lock stuff Jim
loves to popular idea instantly cooler
so I hope nothing is you I think if Papa
locks is my hip right pop locking is
very big in the a different if it was
hey do you remember that break-in
electric Boogaloo yeah I I've heard of
Boogaloo right is that what you just
said
I liked your Boogaloo is a movie was a
sequel to break-in break-in to Elektra
bullet ya know I've seen I'm stayin
alive in Saturday Night Fever stayin
alive is the better ones I don't
disagree
yeah okay cool so sure that face was but
talking moves like just trying to relate
what do I do
so okay we'll take the box out but which
one though this one's done opened the
unopened people got to see what it's
like to get a brand-new fresh pair of
Yeezys okay I'm in the plain box like
that yes made in China look well
casually look really it's a small box
they just be waiting larger can I see
what it says on the label
sure okay it says hey just don't drop
them okay this is akin to something very
fragile
there's literally somebody in pen wrote
in some kind of either Chinese or
Japanese on here there you go which is
it I don't need some dumb [ __ ] this is
what I hate no Bobby says originally
Easy's okay this actually this says uh
men women uni II athletic sports shoe
texts I sent okay uh I don't know made
in China
yeah Adrienne could you help us find the
legit check because I think you can
start with the box and see if the box
matches yeah yeah if you know what a
legit box if the box is different it's
not as legit a lot of people would say
that right and you know obviously not
okay I see here generally speaking the
box says Yeezy boost 350 like it
mentions what shoe it is okay generally
on the other
Easy's and I says those are the fake
ones yeah you might not really that's
fake because it has fake right written
on the box
I know I gotta give away and maybe
superimpose yeah oh yeah that's right
yeah that's right yeah um CC originals
buy original and this is Yeezy 350 boost
that's fake this does not say Yeezy 350
boost on it this isn't the real or the
fake box this is this is the real bot
meaning it's an even worse knockoff I'm
not you're wrong okay maybe I don't know
you want to open them up I don't want to
open them for you this is your big two
thousand dollars shoes for a person you
let him do either what am I supposed to
oh please with yeah exactly
there you go I don't damage the it's got
tape on them yeah right yeah the last no
don't use the pen cuz if you get any ink
on those you know they're not gonna be
worth nearly as much you sell those all
that they're worth yeah I got the tough
Italian fingernail you remember that yes
very good
oh okay torta label he's peeled the tape
right off yeah oh yeah if you're gonna
resell them in the box
it's weird though a lot of shoes come in
shoeboxes no this is a shoe box a box
does choosing it don't you
like you know it opens it's like it's
presented like a like a gift like the
top lifts right Connie doesn't like
wasting time or money is that right
that's right I said got it buddy thanks
a day late in a buck short easily look
at this are they in bags yes they are
okay that's good geez look at that they
are there a bag they're in oh well it's
just one bag the other pair socially
carry medical waste in the other pair
uh-huh um we're individually wrapped
yeah they smell
so the consistency in the packaging
there isn't any there is not as good to
know
right as Kanye is a little left of
center well it's well he is an artist
right so I do think that it everything
is meaning right so the originality and
each is nice now is Kanye
detail-oriented or is he the type of guy
that if he ran out of bags he just used
other bags I think that there is meaning
behind everything he does okay so there
may be some meaning behind this size we
have double hole in his clothing but
that was placed on purpose right I see
okay it's specific they store in that
zip yet so the bag is the meaning is
that's the bag he had I don't I don't
think this represents what happens is
the other pair I have a primate earlier
they came in two bags so one prime
version robbers are going to Kanye and
Kim as two different people but now
they're a family unit that's the union
that none of them is a little shoe a
little showy I noticed the heel on the
one shoe is much bigger that would be
her big ass
I see I think I'm out let's take them
out let's unbox the Yeezys oh here we
are
Lisa Henry was Jimmy swear I got his
special Wow right what Jim OH left yeah
look at that - they look really great
yeah they look right here and I am about
6 feet away thank you
they look like easy as daisies I mean
children size Easy's but ease ease
nonetheless what size of these I don't
know these might fit me actually you
don't know what size they are no I were
three different size wait wait before
you unlace them don't unless that what
or Adrienne legit check well because
when the shoes come they come laced a
certain way yeah now find the laces so
we can see how they're tied in the
bottle it's pretty darn good to find out
because they do well they're easy
they're the most popular shoe there is
does it okay alright doesn't say
anything about laces that's what inside
of the well yeah the inside the more
hung inside the tongue yeah let me see
can I see talk about gym you get throw
it
there we go let's say it says 30 38 so
it's your median sizing your gian sizing
okay it's really is a little baby shoe
oh that's not the one I'm wearing okay
all right you might fit me though they
move okay that would fit you a little
okay there's that I spelled the plural
of Yeezys Yee zy kind of like here okay
now most of the time with ease ease do
you clearly feel and see the glue that's
attaching the sole to the fabric is it I
mean yeah absolutely how this yeah
Jeezy's will stay together that's our
point I'd seem it appears to be very
sloppily good again
are you saying there's a rush job yeah
well that's the Parkinson's section of
at the factory yeah maybe this morning I
made a mistake
yeah what I do like about these shoes is
I have a narrow foot and I feel like
they look out like a narrow cut which
uh-huh yeah they probably do which might
not fit me
the ones I have fit me there's one I'm
looking at here's the the insert yet
with it says the bottom of the insole
you know you can look you can look at
the bottom of the insult to see if it's
legit or not this doesn't appear to have
your toes right it's all right there let
me see laudare bottom okay all right
here we go see real so you can tell on
the real ones they're black right and
they have an adidas logo and there's
markings under it yeah on the fake ones
they're white and there is an adidas
logo but there's no markings these are
red spongy and have no local whatsoever
you think look at look at the fake look
at the fake right these are not them yes
okay no these don't match those fake dr.
Scholl's makes a very nice phone mister
just like those are you gelling like a
fella
John yeah see ya the only thing is that
no I can't find the EZ or adidas logo
that's because you know what you're
doing me anywhere I miss you I do
appreciate though if this is a knockoff
the fact that they just completely
abandoned any attempt friend you try to
make them whatever great would be very
odd person right yeah well let's uh
let's nice let's look at where the logos
are sure aid uh go pass it there you go
okay yeah y'see wife
easy it shows the different fonts the
there would that be that's on that uh
yeah does it say that age I got the
really round ones they're really rare I
got through I got the really uh why are
they so rare because it said I sees like
early on the side of the shoe there's a
little piece of fabric me yeah I don't
exactly know what kind of fabric it is
but it's like it's like a half circle
that comes up from the sole here's the
best part
so what is the half circle say nothing
it's a plane
what happens is yeah did this is like
probably one of the more the rarer
models where they don't even have that
was like the prototype yeah Wow
you're able to get four pairs of the
product yeah that's so cool yeah this is
more chopper you know what this is like
I just reminds me of like Antiques
Roadshow
yeah we're simon afraid something under
like no it's really it's definitely real
my grandmother had this for years and
years like no this is obviously there's
anything under this is 1947 like an old
piece of crap yeah yeah um okay so
you're thinking that's a rarer one that
just doesn't have an adidas or a Yeezy
logo or anything like that right I see
um I I have to tell you I am a little
skeptical
oh it says on the super-sized
on the the sole the adidas logo on the
tri-fold Adrian is there a trifold on
those shoes
what's a trifold you see right there a
trifle is an excellent desert okay that
it doesn't it doesn't appear to have
that part at all yes no it's missing
part of this yeah it's amazing again
these are the probably the originals and
they just made a few changes right well
these are the newer one these actually
buy the newest month it's it could make
you think so there's always there's
always a way out of this Jim now I see
here there are big legs big wording here
it says fake it all the time these
religious these what general whatever
well thank you they are made in China
yes we're really good the real ones are
made in China made in China where were
yours made China hey Chyna
yeah and the fake ones say easy boost on
the tag Jim do yours say easy boost on
the tag oh yeah they do
we're in China there's no tag sure
there's no tag on those shoes I wanted
AG right there look at says yeah you can
see it says size 38 easy boost size 38
what do you think I don't know get an
opinion from oh it's making an
interesting noise we hear that yeah it
clicks a little I remind you the Arvind
young right quick to it I'm slicing it
how's this yeah uh-huh
and it's clicking expect I said hold on
my shoe is loud too that's good let's go
for a walk quickly quickly wide it
that's it clicks a little yeah it's good
sign of a good shoe you know you're
gonna clicks there's a group of people
in China going haha [ __ ] did a real the
CIA the seams on them don't appear to be
quite a fix as well as they could be you
know I mean you can see the glue on them
and the gate clicks from the inside a
little bit I think but here's the thing
that's important we're looking at all
the legit check stuff and the shoe your
shoe does not match the fake shoe right
that's the point I'm making right it's
not a thing if you compare it to the
fake easy it doesn't match it at all
exactly it's that particular fake though
you have to realize you're several
there's not just one guy producing fakes
well it says I mean it's a it doesn't
match the EZ itself either be a new mark
it's a new model and why I said the
original but I think these are the newer
models with a very light weight they're
sleeker right it's a sleek right they
are very lightweight he's probably a
sleek shoe yeah but let me ask you a
question
what's wrong with them they're amazing
the fucsia 20 bucks
exactly I mean what's the next option is
the Walmart velcro peel over that the
old man we're gonna spend the next 1999
I think New Yorker I love fake stuff
going right down to Canal Street yeah
you know I Hackel people down the $20
David Yurman knockoff necklace down to
like $15 you know what I mean like
you're being thrifty and still looking
fly so
yeah but the production company the
production coming is doing your toe is
gonna be very happy about the wardrobe
budget hold on are you saying that you
don't like my socks these are one
looking at kind of socks socks and wear
athletic Kennesaw comedian thing exactly
short socks your short short socks
what's with the what's with the band
around the toes it's just cool
now are you a guy right you know socks
what about how these Tommy Hilfiger ya
know what you should do is wear adidas
socks with the real easy you know you
can imagine Eisley were you because a
penis would make both of them alright so
at least you'll be half right it is
weird though about for adidas to put out
a product like this and not put their
branding anywhere on and you know isn't
that a little mother you know I just
that's being a braggart it's a little
shoe coming yeah yeah exactly yeah but I
don't know if these will fit me or not
oh okay well that's good it's good we're
on Instagram live Adrian is that right
wow that's incredible
Instagram live that Jevons a little
tight a little tight okay that's a
little tighter eyes got bigger the ones
at home fit me well don't don't Pat it
cuz people are gonna want to see on feet
I got a feeling though that if you wear
those for a couple of minutes they're
gonna get bigger just because of the
fact that they're gonna fall apart
you're gonna open up a little bit yeah
yeah hold on
yeah alright alright yeah that's what
about and then you know what you should
do just to see if they work put them on
and then maybe like see if you can riff
a couple jokes yeah just to see if they
feel like is the funnies got to flow
through your body when you're doing this
special on Saturday right it absolutely
does so maybe like see see how natural
see if you can slide into riff mode
while you have your shoes on turn this
way let's do a toe check get a check the
toes look good totally yeah kids so
looks like you're uh you're actually
you're on an ingrown toenail
no I you're all right take care of your
feet they taught me that in the Nam
that's right
oh really try your ankles look like
they're being squeezed out of those
shoes Thanks yeah these are gonna be
these are gonna be so great to all the
young Millennials I got to get the
millenials finally a show yeah yeah this
will be this will be right a little
tight I'll be on these come with
play-doh I want to crying this out
yeah
a pair I have at home fit me perfectly
good
these what's the other ones okay he's
going to check out the other ones right
now I just think it's good that he was
so serious about this like yeah I could
wear these on my special that he really
bought four pairs of them just to make
sure he had the right size what are you
going to do with the other pairs Salomon
let me see probably make a tremendous
profit yeah okay killing yeah these are
40 these are big oh these are bigger you
should give them away at your special
can you go get you know what like we
could like put the number under the seat
and tell the person thank you my gosh
Oprah like the era no get a carry I CLE
only two you are getting.you and you get
a pair you guys and you get very easy
okay hope everybody enjoyed the show
they're expensive guys I'm sorry you
could twenty dollars a pair can't get
him from on ebay they're 1999 with
shipping oh by the way this was not in
the other shoe look at this this comes
up okay ah I mean Jim we should actually
point that out the the issues that we
just opened did not have inserts in them
this one does yes what's this one guys
yeah right that's what they're for yeah
just wear the shoe keeps it shape let's
see what's the insole look like these
are quieter look higher yeah it's gonna
get him oh yeah yeah no no that's that's
the easy noise yeah he samples that in
his music here we go
he's putting it on now yeah better I the
other one still fit a teeny bit better
good good but these are yeah we got to
make sure we have the best fake ups you
have mangoes in case they fall apart
halfway through the set Jim is a
comedian where fashion and function kind
of meet yeah you don't I mean like it
definitely kind of meet and make a
statement they do he always does make a
statement
hey these are great they don't anything
you like all right where am I using for
the special you are gonna wear him yeah
it's good as my best I just got a batch
the city times are you gonna reference
them probably just once um you know cuz
it's a small inside joke for smattering
of girl 5 thing
yeah especially being shown everywhere
yeah you just been working on it for
what year-and-a-half yeah that's fine
just to just throw it all away for a
joke about babies yeah no I like it but
if they're comfortable I would I would
wear them why can't get a hurt as most
of the specially your feet aren't being
shown well why would they hurt Yeezys
are popular because they feel good on
your feet well I'm a weird well let's
say I'd still think we should see if you
can slip into riff mode sure yeah I'm
sorry Jim I didn't mean to run no some
people can't do two things at once no
you're right like tie their shoes and
yeah part of this comedy listen and join
into the conversation yes yes tie the
shoe and host their radio show you know
hey I went over there to tie my shoe I'm
good yeah no you look good dude yeah can
you say it up cuz you look you look
taller like you legs
yeah and I think they might be slimming
too you look good yeah I'd you look good
thing you lack fried in a I feel relaxed
yeah yeah comfy I think it's the shoes
this is cool you know what's nice what
you have the one pair at home they can
be very special the shoes that you
wearing your special and then these are
the shoes that you could just kind of
wear on the streets so everybody can
pass you'll be like Jim are those what I
think they are you'll be like hell yeah
they are or I'm still trying to figure
that out not a hundred percent dynamite
I'm very happy with this purchase you
made a great purchase yeah before if I
went outside I came back with a black
eye so a shade took my sneakers
yeah magic you're being held up it's
that you know you're being mugged
give me your easy you're like I they're
not they would be almost worth getting
shot for somebody got a jail for these
have you walked in one morning with just
a socks on cuz he got robbed for his
fake shoes yeah and then I have 400 in
cash my pocket nothing about the easies
there's a black eye and the $20 these
are real I believe that I feel confident
a little snug in the left one I think my
left foots bigger than my right oh yeah
they have one bigger than you right yeah
yeah these are made one is slightly
larger than the other it's to
accommodate right yeah right um should
we see if anybody in shade 45 is like a
sneaker expert because I kind of want to
impress the neighbors tell them yeah we
got a pair easy just not gonna make sure
they're not on the air and just say hey
I'm Steve sway one
even if not sway anybody and just we'll
just describe to shoot a 45 I just make
them jealous you know yeah that's really
the point it made other people jealous
yeah well let's let's let them know that
we're the supreme morning show you know
yeah do you handle the old school it's
funny I'm wearing a pair of new balance
that I washed and then dry then they got
hung up in the dryer nobody's in there
of that well why is there nobody in
there I guess they're not live I'm gonna
go see ya see ya see if you can find any
of the any of the people on there
we're swag oh that would maybe he's off
today why Ronnie would beat no I don't
care what hot dogs would be to the [ __ ]
he's gonna go and find the guy who I
think programs the hip-hop channel
another test doesn't know that is why we
just put Jimmy on a corner for a little
while if it gets shot and comes back on
those singers think we know it's real
maybe when I get shot come back believe
me today these are gonna be taken if I'm
outside with them can you do any like
like I don't want to put you on the spot
you know I don't like to do that yeah
but is there any kind of improv comedy
that you could throw at us just so we
can see if it works with the shoes I
mean you want to see if I've lost my
edge yeah yeah you've gained it true
I've gained more you're right because
this is the new younger Jim Norton
that's right be sure to window that us
young simple okay hey your pants are
ripped boy [ __ ] Trump
ah pretty cool that's good that's good
actually I'm gonna cry I love to have
ripped pants yeah Trump was not out here
messing them up yeah he's not there
either
oh well maybe they're just late wait
wait did something happen and we're the
only ones that don't know about it
there's no one else to do no one else's
no no no even that guy is gone from the
Oh Travis there
okay hushed she is anybody is anybody in
the offices down there find somebody
from the from buying somebody black yeah
one of them really charlie yeah yeah
that's a good way to spell it out I know
you know I just let it go without being
said exactly I didn't mean to yell Oh
find me you know yeah fight again that's
cool though you look cool thanks a good
gym what oh oh hi Lois Lois step up to
the microphone oh it's good to see ya
yeah Lois here we've been wanting to get
you on chemo yeah we were waiting for
you it's good to see Lois look Jim are
you Ben hi buddy something I know two
things about Lois
number one is exactly what we were
looking for and number two stylin yeah
thank you cowboy nice hat I would
appreciate it snap at Lois Lane season I
love my assigned Adrienne to find
somebody to shave 45 then I said go to
one of the hip hop offices and find
somebody couldn't find anybody
so you think how about Lewis that's like
yeah that'll do the trick
yeah the next step down by Lewis is a
sneaker guy he is he's a bit of us
anybody not your head he went head don't
you where I need to clean these up but
these are ugly Christmas sweater
sneakers right here yes Thank You Man
thank you ugly Christmas sweaters
sb dunks thank you sir that's right
really like about them is that they just
came off tied and they're going back on
all that time the tie thing
yeah what do you think of these Louis
these these are core a very sexy right
you'd like though Jordans yeah as our
amazing
well if you think these are cool reason
I put the I showed you these before Jim
showed you his is because these are just
an appetizer that's right Jim why don't
you let Louis know what's on your feet
he knows he I see the idea of the look
in his eye
what do you see Louis he knows uh some
feces what they see is even Oh
Bridey veteran friends right yeah well
what do you what what you know why
wouldn't you say don't touch him
why wouldn't you say Louis I want you to
know something
yes okay Jim Norton and this is another
reason to idolize this guy not only is
he great comedian smart shopper so how
much how much is it Easy's go for right
now I like $2,000 right you know how
much Norton paid for those 20 clams I
can't do math what's the market I got
them a hundred times at least uh yeah a
hundred times cheap hundred times
cheaper would be to yeah like he had a
hundred pairs for one pair of those
Easy's and I can just sell them and make
a mint now we're trying to figure out if
they're legitimate sale legit before in
they're fake and so far I think the room
is an agreement that they're clearly
real right obviously yes I'm going with
real okay let's see the difference
you're looking at me very crooked what
they're not real this much I mean
they're not real at all why are you like
that
what about show picture easy what makes
the real we lose on the black right in
Seoul he hasn't looked at the tablet I
can do that from here just from the
dollar store sold that's a good damn
just from what size they're like dollar
store soldier supposed to be a little
bit more squishy Jim no no this is these
are Yeezy grips wait wait I know I think
I don't
can you cook Jim can you grab one of the
pair that you're not wearing sure cuz I
know Souris I know why you think this oh
I wasn't sure my chairs I got four pairs
okay but that's not a Yeezy Bob
poisonous come in a cardboard dollar
store box looking like that it's a box
it's not cardboard what kind of box is
it thank you right thank you yes a
strong point right usually there would
be some sort of sign on the front of
this you don't say maybe it would flip
already okay we did actually bring that
up the opening of the yeah I'm a fan of
that'll kind of box our shoe box is what
it's called yes yes presentational box
boxes are showing it okay now wait wait
Jim could you display for Lewis the
sound right that we had found this is
probably well Joanne discovered it and I
Ryan did the same thing
wait
wait wait there it is
it makes a noise that cants not making
it now ya see it's it's got this cool
thing where like when you bend the so
like kind of yeah if you like
oh it's like a click okay okay so in
swimming shoe okay and you said we
wouldn't yeah that is exactly your soul
feels like yes like a water shoes yeah I
might um move it Jim stop real short
when you stop right there amazing though
so go right from the studio to the pool
you don't have to take off your shoes
they are like you slipped loose what's
suspicious to you what's this right here
that's just one of the cool parts of the
easy yeah that's the the pebble under
under only in real Yeezys I'm just lying
right there
you wouldn't know cuz you're not like
Jim you can't afford you know real
Ashley's quick question yeah see this
little velvet part right here yeah yeah
where's that on this shoe on the side
buck oh yeah right but where do you go
insignia right here well you got these
are the newer models these ycy where's
the why don't I stop that's that ones
just plenty to the newer ones yeah
that was just plain that's one of the
plain models this is a new one if you
like shoes minute a car seat material
this is beautiful that's good you think
that's made me now you talk about like a
Cadillac try to get me a murse like a
very nice party how about a Maybach 2002
Honda Civic I'm thinking okay that is
not good car seat so you are not jealous
of Norton shoes I'm not he tore himself
up here he's knocking him down his phone
so he's like oh you have extra pairs
yeah right I'll make it look like these
on a big deal and then I'll get one I
know that's probably what his next day
the was he's like yeah I mean I wouldn't
pay more than $25 for that just trying
to get his hands on him I'm on I'm on to
you Luis what happens when it rains
though does it go right through I
wouldn't wear them in the right that's
smart
Easy's received $20 for the petrol
that's job now also there was something
that I found it I might be just like a
Yeezy thing right like when you hold
them and you look at them close there's
a lot of visible and and tangible
hardened glue
between the fabric and the soul like
where where they met is that just like a
easy thing no I think that's just gym
shoes there they were probably just
running out of the factory okay yeah all
right now Joanne
I got a fresh pair I I had I had a good
observation but Joanne gave me an
explanation that's a Feist one pair of
gym shoes each shoe was in a separate
bag and literally the next pair he
opened both shoes were in one bag and
Joanne was thinking that part of that is
because Kanye likes to do things
differently in he's a bit of an artist
so there's actually there's a meaning
behind every what one might think is a
mistake right or a fake it's really just
an expression of how he's feeling at
that exact moment okay so how do you
think he was feeling putting two shoes
in one fused as we saw by his breakdown
right I think God is doing better
maybe thank God yeah hopefully he's
rehydrated to unity you know people
don't think about water they don't have
right I was worried about him
cuz he was thirsty huh thirsty a [ __ ]
for him yeah I'm glad I've got so where
are you rating these Lewis were my
rating not honor what scale but yeah I
got a scale one to ten ten being a
fabulous amazing easy and one being a
terrible fabrication that you could look
at once without even picking up on
somebody's feet and by the way if you
want to see a recap of this you can go
to this bit is dying job I give him a
four before I give him a four because
you good that's good it's all it's all
on a scale all right like say he was
going by in a car at forty what would
you give him ten ten what is you and be
able to talk but at the same time it's
still Jim Norton so if you see Jim
Norton walking gentle could walk around
with fake jewelry on all day we would
all think it was real thank you you see
Jim Norton walking down the street with
Yeezys on you're gonna see the real no
matter why he probably got some special
edition [ __ ] that we don't know about
yes that's right how about if you see me
prowling the stage like a panther
is that what you do I do
oh wow yeah I got a lot solely back and
forth what uh yeah just like you just
put you're just seeing who's in that
awesome she's right now that you said
jewelry I asked never saying I want some
ice on you I have a Prince Albert I do
it's a clip-on I regret it's amazing
now I have no jewelry no body jewelry
not no tattoo I just I'm too indecisive
and I think the easies are the first
step I do maybe yeah I'm going through a
midlife crisis yeah maybe I'll get like
the little Oh what's that little Brett
thing another cult chin piercing thing
yeah yeah
anyone can those over the lips sure yeah
like drinking with that [ __ ] you know
what I'm saying all the uncomfortable
yeah just just come out stick what
imagine what I love is that is that the
tube in the earlobe right idea and at
what point do you go right I'm 39 it's
time to take it out and then you walk
around you know with two vaginas on your
head really a couple of Hoops hang on
honey
Frank you're only here only as young as
you feel yeah you know you're only as
young as you feel bed by the way those
things smell I was kissing a girl on
time on her neck yeah she had those
things in and I was like oh stuff
collect they're [ __ ] horrible
the next question is oh did you stop no
there you go write that it didn't matter
no I was already done what do the eaters
picked up the bag oh the bag did careful
with that Thanks okay I'm in a loser
school we could actually put that on
eBay the bags probably work at least ten
twelve there's holes in the bag right
there I mean you see easy season shadows
holes in the panting stock I have to
look around you know I didn't think
about that
yeah what Kanye puts holes in his [ __ ]
party dresses you know they're gonna
lose that protects the shoe if it was on
one but it wasn't on the other one
she'll had the answer she would the
others did not have the answer which is
just you know part of it it's part of it
you know it's honesty we thank you for
verifying that these are indeed real
Louis yes I appreciate the verification
and thank you for helping us stretch
something to 45 minutes that was
probably viable for five minutes
oh we have rung this cloth out it's just
a dry stiff cloth you think so ah
horrible